I think Andrew like Kevin kind of stuck  to relationships where Andrew kind of  talks about the powers that be and this  is a little bit of conspiracy so I I  don't I don't know I don't have all the  facts on this but my gut feeling is just  that like he's pissed off some powerful  people based on the stuff he said where  Kevin it was more about relationships  right which is which is good right but  it wasn't gonna piss up off the higher  ups because he wasn't talking about it I  mean Andrew predicted that he'd go like  he'd go to jail and I mean I don't know  I like to wait till all the facts of the  case comes out so you can't really know  but I would be really surprised if he  was involved in anything like that